there's one up right now with CBS have
you seen that one yes
CBS with mark saying something that he
didn't really say one man with total
control of billions of people stolen
down if clearly is a fake video
yeah now in the past you seem to be
against deep fakes and let's get them
down we're surprised that you haven't
taken that one down why well we don't
have a policy against deep fix currently
we're trying to evaluate how did if we
wanted to do that and if so how you
would define deep fix well in this
particular one it looks like he's
talking to CBS n which he isn't yes
saying something that he didn't say yes
good no - it's not good I don't feel
good about it
well you can take it down you know
people well I actually think more than
taking it down I think is a question
about how do we do that in a principled
way we're not gonna make a one-off
decision to take a piece of a video down
just because it's of Mark and Mark
happens to run this place that would be
really inappropriate and responsible we
need to have it define principles and we
need to be transparent about those
principles but it's important seing
people with things that aren't true
that's why it's upsetting I agree with
you yeah but if it takes too long to
identify it at that point the damage is
done we could declare victory but that's
not a victory at all that's totally
hollow so the thing we're focused on
right now very internally is not whether
or not you take it down when you find it
but how do you find it more quickly
because if we don't if a million people
see a video like that and the first 24
hours were in the first 48 hours the
damage is done and so the conversation
though very important currently yeah his
mood but Adam where I leave it up though
when you know it's a deep break right
now we try to balance safety and speech
and that balance is really really tricky
but honestly right now I think the most
important thing for us to focus on is
getting to the content quicker and then
once we can do that then we can have the
next debate about whether or not to take
it down when we find it I'll just say
Adam it's tough to look at that video
going it's wrong I this I struggle with
it too I'm a person - yeah and it's not
like I don't have my own beliefs and I
don't see stuff that violates or
disagrees with me online or on Facebook
or Instagram from time to time